what's up guys greg outta here John
Humphrey here alright so we're gonna
watch the trailer the trailer number
three for wish upon oh hell yeah they
saw one of these trailers together not
like the first one is why I don't barely
remember it
I remember the set up I remember you
know high school some kind of magic box
right I make wish again it's be careful
what you wish for is the theme of it all
the monkey's paw alright would you wish
for their I wish Dorothy
[Music]
and happening right now but never public
sidewalks they and everyone they want
all that real calm again
I wish our work you can't get for
therefore telling you about your
[Music]
I was just stupid on her and why would
there be it doesn't seem like it for a
garbage disposal right there I like the
edge the lip of yeah I didn't look like
yeah this is kind of final destination
II promise you know make wishes but the
elaborate debt trashes that happened the
enigmatic force of death is yeah yeah
yeah exactly that thing at the end was
like nice Mecca just happen to anyone
yes my friends it was clumsy poorly
designed the kitchen yeah you had your
hair in the garbage disposal don't put
it through it yeah baby don't lean with
your ponytail that way and maybe don't
do that if you know that your sink is
built yeah when I make Midway I remember
thing in the first trailer was all right
this is better
I like the trailer better yeah I like
this trailer better it just still one of
those movies that could easily go either
way for me like this could be
surprisingly cool I think it's got all
it needs to do that
I liked casting a lot I'd be very
surprised it was good but yeah I mean
very surprised I didn't see Annabelle I
didn't hear a lot of good things about
Annabelle I kind of feel like this is a
setup for something where you can have a
little bit more fun tone of it is just
seems like a lot of other horror movies
we've seen before
yeah I feel like this is a plot that you
know dealing with wishes and stuff I
feel like you could have you could have
had a little bit more fun with its
personality or style I leave my ground
we're going Trevor I don't know are you
now I mean it looks like the kind of
trailer you see a lot now with a lot of
fast editing a lot of sound blah like
yeah you know like shutterbug yeah
that's like screechie like like been
that opening shot where the box opens up
and you can't tell what's happening
there's just editing and loud noises I
do agree with you ultimately as likely
this is a story I mean granted it's
going to hopefully do its own stuff but
this is the monkey's paw story like this
is be careful what you wish for like the
wishes are going to come out messed up
yeah and you're going to regret this and
it's not going to go the way you planned
and so like it's it's on this movie now
to make something on top of that so
maybe I'm a unique on top of that I
don't see though unique about it though
yeah yet I don't really see much this
special I mean they've got their cool
box
yeah it's rather generic yeah it doesn't
look all that scary the production
values look pretty good it doesn't look
inspiring like it doesn't look like it's
inspired by anything it looks more like
it it's taking from other films that
I've already done plots yeah there is
similar it is it doesn't look like it's
going to take me by surprise at least by
anything that's in here yet I don't know
if they've got some crazy twists up
their sleeve but this looks like a
pretty straightforward curse well that's
why I was thinking like you could have
had more fun with it maybe not make it a
fun movie however you could have I don't
know amped up a little bit of the visual
flair you could have done some cool
practical [ __ ] or you could have maybe
made it make it feel like it will be
more of a fun exciting film amen you
could have crossed over with J Richard
Kelly's the box brought Frank Langella
yeah I would have been a lot more fun no
a lot more fun - I like the Joey King is
in this so like I like her and it's cool
to see her like gonna go the lead role
in something I wish it looks like a
better movie but like I don't know like
some of the performance bits is a little
bits and pieces of like I feel like some
of the actors might be good in them it's
cool to see the guy from kimmy schmitt
actually getting to do an American
accent this is the kind of film that
could work if if the characters are
strong and the character motives and
everything is very character-driven
because this is all dealing with the
consequences of a girl who feels wronged
doesn't have what she wants in life she
comes upon this box that allows her to
wish for things that she wants to happen
for people or happen for her I feel like
this film is going to kind of put a lot
of that could be strong to the side
settle for a bunch of jump scares and
generic horror tropes as opposed to what
would make this work even if it kind of
how does unique well I think will really
make this work as if it was and I'm
going to be calm and saying you should
just watch the movie for the judging and
watch one once even though if this movie
comes out you're gonna I'm gonna be like
yeah I knew it I know it is partly
funded reacting to a trailer is
speculated kind of movie well yeah like
the whole point of a trailer isn't
supposed to be pitching you so yeah and
I'm wishing two of these trailers so far
and granted this trails better than the
other one so it's like cabin fever a
little bit of final destination has like
a lot of other high school horror flicks
though the whole wishing thing is
generic but like my favorite moment is
when hot girl wakes up and her skin is
falling apart and I feel like playing
more to those kind of things would have
made this better playing more to the
evil disgusting stuff would have made it
a little better I'm curious about that I
mean because that that rotting scene
does look gross and I don't think we get
very many other hem set like what the
specific wishes are going to be it looks
like a lot of people are gonna die in
this hell yeah
well that's what I mean by how it seems
like it's going to ten more to horror
movie cliche trips as opposed to it's
definitely loading in on things building
up and getting worse and worse the
hopeful side of the spectrum what you
would want is like this looks like if
you did this like really right this
could be one of those like paranoid
movies were like over the course of it
the main characters like deteriorate I
mean you know there's a lot of stuff you
could do with this and the best idea
this trailer gives me is it looks like a
like a solid spooky death curse movie
but not a lot more no I hope it's kind I
think this move along I can be honest I
kind of do too I don't want like the
thing is I never want to be a lobby but
I would like to be on right when I
predict something that's the best part
of the coaster me yeah unless there's a
surprise like I said I didn't hear a lot
of good about Annabelle so I'm pulling
for this guy like I want you to have a
good one because they have generic luck
that's kind of what I play what a
mystery but you know like it's not hard
to do that out of
you know like a franchise spin-off like
there are a lot of generic spin-off I
don't know the origin of this but this
is baby it's so like it would just be a
bummer and that turned out to be kind of
fine harder than this
oh yeah Barbra I saw her good good for
her good for her for a lot of these are
it's cool why these guys got a check you
know as long as I got a good paycheck to
keep them working in this business I'm
happy for him I think this guy directed
Mortal Kombat annihilation to really
look at this directors credit or I'll
call 9i elation to butterfly effect to
animal eyes I just don't think this is a
solid I mean he's a word he's a like
guys worked on a lot of films as a
cinematographer and like that's what I
mean like some a shot look cool but even
as a guy who comes from the
cinematography bath radical look I think
he could look even cooler yeah I don't
know I thought the look was fine there
were shots I thought was neat and stuff
like that like the production values
what fun M&S I guess what's confusing to
me about this rather it looks like they
actually had some money to make this
even though it looks like kind of a
standard straightforward little low
budget movie it looks like a low-budget
movie with beefier production value and
whatever is alright well would you guys
think of the trailer give your honest
opinion below honest stupid easy you
hate me for bagging on a trailer or you
hate me for kind of agree with you ya
can't comment now you can't comment you
like everything good I love it when that
happens like every you like everything
for your video was up sue do you look
good and then when you raised a
complaint it just becomes you know yes
good might be true the bees don't look
this a little bit is what's wrong with
you
well you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification valve
John is that John Humphrey on Instagram
and Claire is a social media manager for
Blum house.com
place that actually makes really good
horror and you can check out our patreon
go do yourself a favor and check out our
exclusive goodies over there we get out
with the video content a lot of awesome
rewards that you can go and find out
what hell we got to offer over there
you know it's worth it people or their
career
we might get naked maybe maybe you'll
see my left but to cool
but to cool
I can't go in restricted mode but achill
I have I don't think it'll read into a
testicle or ass